yeah we're ready special guest all the
way from new york new york maybe maybe
you've seen him on the nick cannon show
yeah wendy williams crazy daytime what
are you doing on daytime talk shows do
you hate selling comedy tickets what's
happening here give the kid a break he
knows are you having fun no no no no
he's only doing black audiences though
wendy williams nick cannon nick cannon
and you're almost too much for them no
well that's that's he's too much that's
right i once said a joke he said a joker
nick can't even result yeah
yeah but that's yes that's the bit
brendan that's what i'm doing
that's that's that's what no that's what
i'm doing is i i go on these [ __ ]
shows and i'm like you know what if i'm
gonna go on this [ __ ] i'm gonna do it on
my own terms they told me the nick
cannon producers they told me that
morning they said hey we saw your little
christy daytime tv thing with wendy
williams they said you know it's funny
we respect but they said but this is a
live show this is a live show so we
really you know we put governors on put
governors on yes wrong thing you say to
a comic so
as soon as the show opened you know i
just went christmas day times i said i
have i have an uncircumcised penis and
it's it's you know it's ready to go and
they and they just were like what nick
cannon was politely laughing did both
shows wendy williams and um uh nick
cannon show i i did not get paid
i was not given the sack paper you
breached the contract i just left but i
will do that if you're a daytime
if you're a daytime tv show producer
i'll come in and i'll give you a little
cd tv christy day times shake it up
shake it up shake it up and then because
i'm going to come in there because the
thing is i believe if you're getting
actual laughs on daytime televisions
you're doing [ __ ] jokes so i'm
coming in there just swinging do the
curveball
throw a curveball now the question was
does it sell tickets no
so no i know we're struggling in some
theaters out there pick it up but you
know what you know what
he's doing a huge theater play chrissy
theaters everybody had the cte tour yeah
yeah so do you remember um gary
shandling remember the great great
one
and gary shandling was a guy who just
would never i did a couple shows with
him benefits with him and he was just
always he stopped doing stand up for a
while but he was he would always bring
it and he was just so smart and
everybody else and he said um jerry
seinfeld said i never feel comfortable
at hollywood parties yeah and and
shandling said well
the minute you feel comfortable at
hollywood parties
is the minute you become billy crystal
which means you're not funny anymore
yeah so if you're funny on a on a
[ __ ] daytime show that's safe get the
[ __ ] out you're boring to me yeah once
you've gone to hollywood like you're out
of the crew dude yeah you can't do it if
you got in hollywood you can't be on
here yeah no they were like they were
like hey can we hear some of your jokes
like in the rehearsal i was like no i'm
gonna do them for the first time live
maybe are you out of your mind we were
you were you contrasting that beautiful
green with your eyes
hold on no you're
you're going a little hollywood on us
though yeah no i'm a theater place
you're kind of you're messing with the
kids ambitious he's having fun to get
out he does it in a fun way i'm trying
to get out there because you know
somebody's got to pay that alimony so i
i went on that
show that nick cannon show they told me
to dress professionally nice and i went
on with a sweatshirt that said bing bong
i went over
i swear to god bing bong sweatshirt and
pants from old navy with mismatching
socks oh wow and low top uh nike's that
hurts my feelings yeah and i didn't nick
cannon had on probably a five thousand
dollar suit yeah the situation had an
assistant that was pressing his clothes
and they asked me several times do you
have any other outfits i said absolutely
not they said well we don't know if we
can license that i said not my problem
babe that's what i
you're probably not coming back yeah
because i because the thing is i think
you have to go into those things knowing
like i don't give a [ __ ] if you never
invite me back i'm doing this for me and
my clips i'm not doing this for the
audience yeah yeah
i had an acting
teacher who told he told the class he
goes when you go into an audition when
you go on an audition you you tell them
how it goes
you tell them well use well he goes you
now now you'd go
i got the you guys got the spirit of
what you're saying i got the spirit
right we take a little this take a look
at this not brad pitt you tell them how
it goes so
we had this [ __ ] dumb dumb in class
there's always a couple part of being in
an acting class is watching a train
wreck right this was a dumb dog well no
one's going to make it oh no
no one's going to and you have the ones
that have their their dream boards and
all that and this is one of those people
and apparently they went in and i only
know this because i have a friend who
was a producer on the show and said she
comes in
and she goes this is how it goes guys
and everybody goes huh and and they go
that that's kind of bold and she goes
all of you you sit here
i said that i do i sit there. and so oh
we're good so it'd be like this and and
she decided to shake the room up a
little bit you guys are going to she has
no credentials nothing no yeah and they
went we're we're fine sitting here and
she was like oh
yeah okay
then she started shaking she didn't
think about that they went well no shut
up [ __ ] do the thing yeah yeah so she
went yeah things no things never
worked out yeah i mean
like chris chris christie hold on but
you missed the cab ass fight companion
which will reach a million views
whatever but i know instead i did the
tampa theater
how did how'd tampa go it actually was
great shout out to fans of tampa theater
missed a salad by a hundred tickets so
not terrible not terrible 1100 1200
that's pretty big boy
big boy
1100 yeah boy and i say 1100 so it's
really was 980 but you know we're on
that's comics though
like your golf score is that's what it
is
i shot at 90. what are you yeah dude i
sold out five shows in my i'm like yes
no yeah you know i i may throw it out
three though it's fine
but you sold out three yeah yeah yeah
yeah i go dude
five [ __ ] sorry damn that's crazy
before you tell me that i'll go online
to briancon.com i'll look through if
it's sold out four out of five ain't bad
why don't we do that to each other
what's because we lie because we're
liars i don't know but we're horrible
people that's why we're wind up where
we're at
we're [ __ ]
dude if we were decent human beings we'd
be doing you know what i mean i'd be a
teacher so i'd be chin chin's a good guy
and i said i said before the show
started chin you've gotten taller what's
your secret his neck is [ __ ] up and
they started wearing a neck brace
that's actually
possible oh for sure i've been doing
traction which just pushes your head off
ginseng
right here six seven really ginseng i
knew something was wrong with chrissy's
uh neck the minute he walked in yeah you
walked in
you had your arm your your hands were in
front of your knees your very long arms
thank you so your arms were
i don't know if that's a it's coming no
it's hard work and dedication no you've
got good reach you got good reach yes i
do and you your your knuckles were sort
of
you walked in a little bit like a
knuckle dragger right 100 percent yeah
i said something's wrong with his yes
you have he's got bad posture today and
it's because if i have a neck issue now
i think my neck issue could be directly
related to how much time i'm spending on
a phone cramped over computers you know
dealing i have a six month old baby
seven month old baby so on the floor
dealing with that but i did i pulled and
i'm gonna be honest with you i'm honest
with the group i pulled my neck on the
eighth
pull-up of the first set
strict pull up too
this morning and you're smart
three four days ago hands this way he's
very full clean you know as long might
you know stretch my long
long arms and then all the way chin over
the bar was one and on the eighth one
popped popped my vertebrae yeah yeah
yeah so we're set first set
we're the similar age right i'm 30 uh
seven years old 19 38 83 we're getting
older daddy
i didn't blow out one hamstring i blew
out both strings yeah and to blow out
both hamstrings i mean it's just a funny
thing it's like it's torque it's it's
torque too much storage it's like it's
like you got to do a store [ __ ] idiot
you know blow out both it's like it's
like you're fully [ __ ] but you know
i agree that's what it is straight up
peanut butter falcon yeah but
did daddy not come running into the
studio this morning it wasn't running it
wasn't good because it was good i i
thought he was throwing out i begged him
to warm up there was none of that and
then when i saw him pop both i went well
we're done for the tough mudder because
i i do the thick mutter on saturday
we're all doing it and you're going to
do it with pop tammies and all daddy's
getting better he's a tough kid he's
been rehabbing his stuff though he
happened i'm jose canseco right yes i
haven't had a carbon two and a half
weeks i got more illegal supplements
rolling through this body to feel to
cure this hammy than [ __ ] alex
rodriguez
oh endurance thing is that yeah oh it is
oh yeah i thought it wasn't i've never
felt better really really i thought you
need carbs for long distances excuse me
55. no it's it's it's it's no i'm just
saying it's like the the nutrients you
get from red meat and all that stuff yet
we're gone
on wednesday are you not 45 you turn 55
on wednesday
55 with you ready
i'm getting older i don't i don't do trt
yeah and what are you 29 waist i got i
got a 32 waist at the end because you
got a bit of a dumper i got an ass oh he
does have an apple box i got an ass on
me holy crap b only four teams remain in
the nfl playoffs and that means only
four teams left for you to bet on dude
with draftking sportsbook the official
sports betting partner the nfl counting
down to superwall 56 right here in los
angeles california new customers can get
56 to one odds on any team bet just five
dollars and get 280 in free bets if your
team wins bet on the rams not a new
customer cool you can experience the
conference championships with the same
game parlays combine multiple bets from
the same game for a bigger payout the
more legs you add the more money you win
draftkings is safe secure reliable best
of all deposit withdrawal whenever you
want download draftking sportsbook right
now all right download the app use promo
code fighter and get 56 to one odds on
any nfl team bet just five dollars and
win 280 in free bets if your team wins
that's promo code fighter for 56 to one
odds at draftkings sportsbook bet on my
rams the official sportsman partner the
nfl must be 21 or older new jersey
indiana pennsylvania only new customers
only minimum 5 deposit one dollar wage
are required one per customer restricts
the play see draftkings.com sportsbook
for details gambling problem call 100
gambler
ballsy it's about balls dude look at the
end of the day
you want to take care of your balls your
balls are prone to odor sweat to
irritation upgrade your nuts if you got
the balls balsies your freaking customer
i mean or your product is what i should
say they make quality long-lasting
products formula to keep you fresh
comfortable
confident talk about the products dude
you gotta check out ballsies my balls
are freaking glistening man we love
ballsy they make men's products for the
man parts the groin area the products
i'm glad you asked don't think for one
second that ballsy is just trimmers
they've got your sack covered with the
ball wash sack spray and so much more
it's for all the bros man and it's great
ingredients all right you're not sure
where to start once you take their
little quiz about your nuts they
customize and tailor it just for you man
it's made in the u.s of a
all right and they guarantee with over
200 000 satisfied customers a 30-day
money-back guarantee we've got to give
balls a try all right so keep the funk
off your junk right now if you go to
ballwash.com
put promo code fighter 20 you'll receive
20 off that's 20 off plus free shipping
when you go to ball wash dot com promo
code fighter 20. apple box i got an
assignment you know what buzzing out
though more than anything his birthdays
why why how long are we going to do this
he only has
maybe 10 more good well because you're
65. we can't well we can't be talking
about
yeah yes we can 65. we'll see what
happens celebrate at 55 i i i am my body
is much more delicate so i do lots of
pt stuff like for my back and neck so
that stuff because that's just
stuff yeah all that [ __ ]
but you but
5b you think we're still gonna be
[ __ ] around man i don't know you're
depressing me man
i really i don't even acknowledge your
birthday i want to pretend you're
peterborough same way dude and i am and
i still got lots of energy and i'll be
running that tough mudder no problem
yeah it might be a problem for me i'm
gonna do it what what's your sign
i'm an aquarius thank you thank you for
what are you nice dude i'm a virgo
virgin september
august 26th baby 1984 same birthday as
macaulay culkin oh what can you do home
alone
do you uh did you have some speed did
you have a lot of fat because you're
german a lot of people don't realize
that chris stephanos very very very
little basketball mostly mostly german
same german
a hint of irish and british yep so
but mostly german and um and i i i
basketball i willed it to happen i could
jump i used because right now i'm
sitting here at a comfortable 242 pounds
right hey hey
are we 42 or you're like 45 46 you think
let's go 250. yeah yeah
i got to keep a man honest
you know i'm probably 62. i also had a
blueberry muffin toasted with butter
this morning god that's good why would
you do that because i'm depressed
brenton why because my tickets aren't
selling on the theater tour and i was
putting too big of venues at two high
ticket prices but that's why and who
told you i know yeah
yeah baby well nobody takes it more
personally than he and i yes no no no no
no nobody's
when does nobody frustrates me more than
chrissy d why what no what yeah cause he
doesn't listen to you he's the he's the
next he's he's it he's the next guy in
new york
it went schultz went tim dillon you know
it's it's you know these guys ching gil
is [ __ ] mark norm that the new york
guys are crushing now and chrissy d's
more talent than everybody
and he doesn't [ __ ] listen i don't
listen but hey i wanna i wanna hit him
that's you do you wrap him up hit me
dude don't do that come no i can't
myself oh god
crossing the crib dude you hit me in the
chin it's like sticking your finger on
my prostate
hanging out
yeah
you don't want to hit that must have
dropped you dude yeah you smelled her
perfect
i would assume you came in all bunched
up with your neck and your back because
your schedule is [ __ ] nuts why are
you doing all this man okay chill out
and this comes from a guy who doesn't
chill i got 100 podcasts i know no that
that's
it's too much i think i what happened
was let me let me when does this episode
come out tonight tonight oh tonight look
at that welcome so here's the good news
here's the good news on the chrissy
theaters everybody tour the hashtag cte
tour we got
i'm christy northeast borgata we got two
shows sold out beacon theater new york
city 2700 new jersey
27 hundo's not bad you sold out the
beacon that's a big big deal and that
one's gone
dude
is big too and you're depressed your
boys your thousands your boy's done
bargaining
well hold on let him finish let's cause
i'd be depressed let's get to the next
phase let's let's start going midwest
let's go texas well no well no texas i
did good austin we had it with vulcan we
sold a lot of tickets that's like huge
dude now but 1500 by the end of the
thing so that's good
making money here's where we get here's
where we get a little dicey okay
warner theater washington dc that's
another big boy 1900 they've been on
sale six months got about 350 tickets
that's that's an honor that's it now
that's i would cancel i'm very good
that's february 11. hey kristy people
watching dc you might get a chris scott
covid email next year
that's what i told him to do then we got
here's another here's another fun one
then the very next day february 12th we
got the tabernacle here in atlanta
another big boy we're 2100 and we got
235 seconds okay that's a chocolate city
you're out of here that's a chocolate
that's a chocolate city that's a
chocolate city yes atlanta that's a
chocolate
that's a little tough sometimes because
here's the thing what's my guess is
chris 3 000 you're right yeah my guess
is my guess is bubba that you're you're
in certain areas in blue states you're
you might have because they're not
listening to that man [ __ ] no new york's
blue though yeah
new york's got a lot of you know
old-school italian irish guys they're
all over that they're all coming i mean
you got jersey forget it it's they think
it's blue but it's not in a lot of ways
yeah but but but but i'm talking about
in a lot of places like california and
[ __ ] like san francisco yeah bro no
here's where we get good again but then
we got the agora theater in cleveland
and the royal oaken in detroit those are
uh march fourth and fifth donnie depeda
aka uh chubby uh
uh-huh
yeah
no also also known as
the third mario bro
he comes up to me goes hey man we went
before i go well how am i supposed to
recognize that yeah i love the mustache
perfect yeah wait so how are we doing in
those so the agora theater uh and and
and the royal oak theater in detroit
michigan march fourth and fifth we're
doing pretty good on those are about 50
to 60 sold to the room about a month out
those probably might go those are when
it gets
dicey again though there we go
is um we're getting pretty hairy at the
win in las vegas
for you
[Applause]
because katy perry's next door
because we were going up against a
little woman named adele but she can't
cancel thank god
march 17th and 18th at the moore theater
and the revolutionary hall in portland
we're not doing terrible not doing great
where it goes a [ __ ] nosedive is the
egyptian room april 8th in indianapolis
that's another big boy
yeah we're we're have you ever do you
even sell out clubs no i don't
i don't have 13 tickets
here's another issue a lot of people
don't have money in those areas yeah
that you're talking about i 160 160
dollars for the front row oh you're
right
i went ahead don't get me started
yeah yeah okay so let's do this i love
how honest you are
the average american has 500 in the bank
yep you you're asking you're going to
spend they're in their entire bank the
economy's doing all right it's not that
it's it's ju
wrong mark he went from clubs to giant
theater oh here's another skip the
middle here's another fun one i sold out
four clubs at zany's in chicago okay
last year
i said hey yeah i saw that four shows uh
in chicago
i said let's go to the chicago theater
36 hundo and uh that was that's march
12th that one's not too terrible listen
that only got about 14 1500 tickets sold
so it's not terrible but i should have
just done the vic which is a thousand
seats and then we added a show but
instead i went right to the chicago
theater
i liked your mentality
i skidded off a little bit what'd you
say i like your mentality like that
mentality then your your management
should be like oh dude 100 should be
doing those why don't we play well i'll
tell you what brendan i'm sitting here
right now as a free agent baby no you're
not i cleaned millionaires no you're not
really i had to baby i said don de pet
is my [ __ ] agent now and you're going
to deal with his mustache
that's who's booking the gigs why don't
you have brendan schaub manage you i
should i'm gonna have christian paolo
manage me because i want to get in the
black community through his brother
hey i got something so uh so they booked
me at the hard rock in oklahoma and it
seats
i think twenty four hundred it's big
seats like twenty four hundred and i was
like yeah oklahoma they give you a
guarantee no casinos because it's bigger
you get you see the money so they go if
you sell out you get this much i'm like
holy [ __ ] if i could sell it so we do
all this marking around that number we
get there uh on friday shows on saturday
and on friday look at no tickets are for
sale i'm like holy [ __ ]
sold out i'm already thinking about i'm
telling my openers dude you guys getting
bonuses we're selling this stuff out
there's a tornado alarm there's a
tornado thing going on so the line
outside goes scattering they run they
[ __ ] spray i'm like well that ain't
good oh well we're sold out i'm sure
they'll come back
so i'm sitting there and the uh
the owner or the like the guy who
managed stuff cowboy hat he comes and
goes you you you boys ready i go
no there's a there's a tornado alarm bro
that nobody's out there i looked out
there's six people in the crowd dude
that's sold out and he goes is that a
fact i go
yeah it's fact i'm not going out there
dude there's six people out there i'm
gonna wait till they come back from the
tornado he goes no you're gonna start
no i promise you i'm not those six
people you can bring him in the green
room i'll do the show here yeah i'm not
going to that giant theater and i go uh
and then he goes okay and he goes uh
we'll figure it out and he goes here's
your check too i'm not gonna stay for
the show here's your check give me the
check i look at you go oh oh real quick
sir
it's sold i know there's tornado and all
that but it's sold out and i'm supposed
to get the bonus and he goes oh yeah i
go yeah he goes come talk to my office
somewhere all right go to his office
i sit down and he goes sir he i'll never
forget this he goes here here's the
facts here's the facts i want to say i
embarrass you in front of your friends i
don't want [ __ ] [ __ ] your friends
around here nobody know who you are
not even close son
he goes we reserve some tickets because
when it's selling well we reserve some
for the whalers and the people that play
out there and it just wasn't selling
here he goes now maybe in new york
california they know who you are around
here nobody knew who you are this is
what you can do you can take this money
not a lot you can take this money you
can go out there give one hell of a show
i go
there's six people out there who goes i
don't care you're gonna go out there he
goes cause you're on native american
time he goes and we can't start late son
you're on native american time wow now
this guy wasn't [ __ ]
okay i went
like how did you why did you think it
was sold out because it said there's
because it didn't say sold out just you
couldn't buy tickets so i assumed sold
out of course of course of course dude
those were the reserve tickets then no
it just wasn't selling at all and
they're like oh
so oh
two days before they pull it all
together
do you have a special and then i'll
never forget comedy central i'll never
forget he kept saying i'll never forget
ephraim i will never forget this kept
saying nobody knew who you are
nobody knows who you are new york
california new york california here
i'm sure that's fine here and he goes
son i'll give you this you got a tornado
warning that ain't fun and the oklahoma
sooners are playing today that ain't
good for you either you gotta go well
you booked me man yes
it is what it is yeah well that you know
he said we might have you back dude oh
he goes you go out there give a good
show we might have you back
i never come was it actually a good show
though probably the crowd was probably
happy to see you that's fine but that'll
that'll make you feel so heavy that'll
make you like hey
nobody knows who you are i need to do
cooking nobody know who you are yeah and
then go into my mind
my openers like dude you remember myself
give me those bonuses and [ __ ] dude that
ain't happening because daddy didn't get
paid you remember in the dark days for
daddy uh when when i wasn't doing
fighting the kid and nobody knew when i
was coming and i was i called him up
because i had no one else to talk to i
called him up and i was like i want to i
want to kill i want i want to kill i
want to kill everybody and myself as
well like because you're in seattle on a
thursday and there's seven you go
there's not much i know you're really
pissed there's nothing i can say is
going to make you but you try to give me
some excuse but you know what is covent
uh yeah and i i i would have done if you
said brian i if you said brian
you you can do all that cocaine that's
what i would have needed to go out there
but you know what daddy did daddy
studied ticket sales and venues
so i think that there's a business side
to it yeah where i think um yeah now
it's what some of these theaters are
going to be it's going to be the chrissy
the chrissy curtin's show because
they're going to just have to put the
curtain down and some of it and then
it'll make it feel that's that's what
you want to hear from your agent oh it's
going to feel good though we have the
curtain down
the audience
they go no dude what they do the
curtains it's going to feel like a tight
room it's going to look packed sure it
is like yeah no i got i think i think
it's about you know when you here
because you know what happened is i was
like it was the first time i ever really
started selling tickets you know ever in
my career so i was like oh and shows it
comedy clubs every comedy club i went to
sold out and a show it's all good good
good so i was like let's go let's let's
do theaters let's try it and i realized
i'm a i'm a regional guy i realized that
in in the northeast i mean i mean i'm uh
in new york i can do it like yeah we're
good i'm good but then when it gets a
little hairy when you go to these other
cities where like you know like you said
no money or maybe you know they just
don't know how to indianapolis politics
it's not that you can't do those it's
that
in your management which is [ __ ]
awful which is in those new york markets
and the east coast market you should be
doing that the rest you shouldn't you
shouldn't be making those leaps no
nothing that you look bad because then
the fans come like dude there's nobody
oh yeah no it's brutal so was the move
to just keep it to the clubs for a bit
even if you are adding no there's money
there's money in theaters but it's only
if you can sell certain amount of
tickets yeah like in new york and
wherever new york new york boss
connecticut any northeasterly philly
we're in a little bit of trouble too
because philly what we did was we did
that we did the philly punch line in
august and we sold out eight shows so
that's nice sell out eight very nice
that's nice yeah because that's bad 400
people that that was third three
thousand tickets but but then you're
doing atlantic city right now we're
doing the borgata goes there sold out
who all goes there and then what we did
is we said april we said april 29th
we're gonna do a casino in bethlehem
that seats 2 000. then the very next day
april 30th we're going to do the met
which holds four thousand hold on
this is all in pennsylvania yeah well
who's doing this to you i i was
this
the agent chris like i i i would have
told you
no no i would have told you it's a crazy
[ __ ] i've ever heard in my life no no i
tell him i tell my agent i'll go dude i
think you should do staples like i want
to do you know but yeah no he's like no
no no dumbass there's a plan yeah no you
don't go from here to there
so i [ __ ] up so what we're gonna do
what you'll see in philly most like is
what you're gonna see an email about a
little thing we like to call a venue
change and your tickets are probably
gonna be good uh for for that we're
purchasing ready for the match and we're
probably going to be going to the
fillmore which is a little bit smaller
and when i stay a little bit smaller
about 3 000 seats smaller
we're gonna start there and we're gonna
see how it goes yeah we're also gonna
move the show because i just did 18 000
shows in philly in august and then i did
another show in morgana we're gonna move
that date from april 30th 2022. do i
want to say september 2023 yeah yeah
that's what we're going to do yeah
because we're going to need to give the
people of philadelphia rest time
you're gonna need new jokes and a new
act yeah because i don't have i have an
hour special out brian asked me a size
38 race on comedy central which only the
people in this room ever saw because
comedy central i mean it's just it's
literally it's an underground youtube
network
netflix said no to me hbo show everybody
said no to my new house so we're going
to just go put it on the tube
on the youtube and that's what's going
to sell more that's probably going to
sell more tickets so so so i'm fine with
it but yeah it's an interesting
interesting thing because you know i the
one positive thing i'll say about
absolutely [ __ ] failing at some of
these theaters is
it's not a i've it's i've proven at
least to myself it's really not about
the money i do do comedy because i truly
love it because i'm making even the
guarantee on these theaters you're going
to make money yeah and i'll bring money
back home to my family but i feel like
such a pitiful depression there's
nothing worse so there's actually a
positive thing where i'm like oh at
least i love stand up and i always knew
i did but it's like just a confirmation
and be like i love doing the podcast but
i'm a stand-up comic yeah that's what i
always when you learned something you
learned i learned something by the way
here's another new agent his name is
justin
yes
i saw him last night that's the guy yeah
i was with him last night man [ __ ]
great i was with him last night i never
do that to you good just good justin ed
brooke he he's very smart and he i know
i know we were talking we were talking
last night so i'll see what happens dude
i'll see what happens but i'm out here
on the pod if you guys want to come to
the theater show christy comedy.com uh
you know you might get some emails about
you know some last minute covet changes
but don't worry your tickets will be
honored and if you have a problem you
can dm me or
you know ticketmaster yeah yeah
don't take it but don't worry babel take
care of you but forgotten beacon i i
love how honest you are about it like
because it's like [ __ ] have to
[ __ ] because what am i i mean dude
my a and then i was and how about this
then i was uh uh in the tampa theater
last week which was great told you miss
missed it by you know 100 300 sale
tickets but not bad but you know 84
percent of the room not bad um so so we
got a nice lift on the meet and greet we
got we got all the money in the meet and
greet so it's nice um and by the way
people on the tampa mean great i do want
to tell you i had slight body aches but
nothing to be concerned about
but but the day before that i was
supposed to be co-headlining the hard
rock in orlando with andrew dice clay
and andrew dice clay
calls me a week before and he goes baby
he goes chris and he goes uh i can't do
the show with you next week i got
belle's palsy so i was like oh [ __ ] okay
helen cells eating those balls you guys
know what that is yeah it's like where
is
so i said all right i said fair enough
so he said but we're going to do a show
together in march we're going to read
book show in march i said absolutely i
said i'll cram it right in there with
the rest of my shows that are [ __ ]
bombing i said no problem i said so so
let's do it so i i said he said we're
gonna do it in march i said okay so then
my agent calls me
an hour later and he says hey i got you
an offer uh uh for october at the hard
rock in orlando i said well i don't want
to be a dick to dice i'm not going to do
that to dice i said i i i wanna i'm
gonna do the show with him in march she
was like what are you talking about i
said
dice called me and said we're doing the
show together in march he goes dice
booked himself for march baby you're
doing a solo show he's doing a solo show
so you're [ __ ] out of here so i said
wow that one hurt
so now let's see let me see i'm on i'm
on sale october 22nd at the hard rock in
orlando if you want to come i'm gonna be
wearing a [ __ ] mickey mouse hat
going to do the whole show with a noose
around my neck
how did you line up with andrew he
messaged me andrew dice clay reached out
to me i i love andrew dice i'm a big fan
but he messaged a legend he messaged me
and was saying all these complimentary
things i was like i want to do a show
with you wanna so we we booked this show
and then it just it just fell through
but it it is it is just funny how like
you know that's the whole thing with
this business is like you just [ __ ]
ups and downs you know and i think i'm
on and up but it's just funny it's just
funny like when you see this
cause some of these some of these you
know the agent will send you know the
venue size the ticket sales and their
percentage and some of these percentages
are in the single digits yeah i mean
some of these percentages look like the
weather in buffalo and that is not good
the pods are great chrissy chaos every
tuesday 11 a.m eastern time and hey babe
with salvato every thursday 11am eastern
time those are good and that's the
beautiful part about potting is you know
the patreon patreon.com christy comedy
dude i did mushrooms on my patreon last
week and because i do a thing on the
patreon my patreon called the chris and
eddie show where i used to take edibles
which i would call eddie's where i would
you know say this chris and any show i
never did drugs i would take an edible
for the patreon and we do show but now
it's like morphing into things but last
week i took a a uh uh um
uh mushrooms on the podcast like
chocolate mushrooms or just
philosophical what was that what was
that chris
dude it re-shaped my brain because my
brain i used to get all bent out of [ __ ]
it's a positive and a negative what
happened because the positive was it
reshaped my brain and kind of redid some
pathways to like not beat myself up so
much and just be who cares go with the
flow but it also said to myself to just
be happy with my my body and my life so
now i've been eating a lot of muffins
because i don't care anymore because i'm
like on snapchat you know i'm happy
having tits but what's gonna happen is
i'm going to wake up one day yeah and be
like am i in a fat suit yeah yeah yeah
i'm sorry i know you know
now with that with old people looking at
death it's got better results than
almost anything yeah mike tyson you know
he did that whole thing with this woman
where he was from something yeah that
dude [ __ ] said that's what he credits
that for his sort of peace of mind no
there are a lot of they also do with the
fraud but they also do impression
but they've ct for
fighters incredible i'm so open about
whatever the things going on i'm telling
you the mushrooms are the thing and next
week for the chris and eddie show at
patreon.com christy comey we're going to
do uh you know because it's always like
some type of substance that we take and
we'll do the show next time i'm going to
get the booster and then do the show
there's a woman the booster i'm gonna do
i'm gonna get two boosters in each arm
and just do the show
there's a woman in la who works with a
lot of people including tyson who you'll
she'll take you away for it's a four day
retreat ask if she wants to buy some
tickets to dc i will
i will i have friends who did that what
what they think
i don't know man you know yeah i think
you're okay
yeah what would you use it for just
curious you don't have cte you don't
have anything curious you have ptsd you
just want to experience it
ptsd what though you saw no war action
you know okay he's been through i mean
it can help with therapy i would
most people that do it see a therapist
all the time can you say therapist
you might as well do it see how you feel
i would say do it christian why are you
beat red what the [ __ ] is going on why
are you red he's a huge fan dude and he
is he loves he's like chris did you did
you take it laughing are you going to
claim butyrol or some [ __ ]
oh really because i have video proof
that you're doing computers jesus i knew
it man
i'd love to see it no yeah your brother
your brother was shooting up tests in my
house last week
he asked me to do it to him before well
yeah dude he's it's terrible to talk
about a good-looking kid yeah
he got sure he actually he did i i did
mushrooms with his brother oh he took
some mushrooms too i don't know if starz
is upset with that or not um
and then he sat on my lap he sat on my
lap on the show oh yeah go go to christy
comp well yeah go to gianni if you want
what's what's this is it
look at this kid's body he's got a rock
in our body smaller man smaller
why would he why would he sit in your
lap because we were just we were on
mushrooms and we just went from let's go
to a wild shadow band probably he might
be shadow band probably wouldn't
surprise me
here we go go down that's my by the way
this is my father tampa tony um he came
to the show tampa tony mann's those
shirts made up why is he dressed like
that well because those who's your uncle
he's andrew dice
i know that's tampa tony and he took
pictures with about 50 women whitney
cummings said is he single um yeah dude
he has he had to go zoom out a little
bit he wanted to wear his new diabetic
socks i mean these are new [ __ ]
pressure socks he was when he pulled him
up to his nutsack
what shoes are those no when you look at
my father if you look at it quick you
say does a guy have special needs and
the answer is i don't
uh know yeah so that's that's my pops
but if you go back uh uh to the to the
took mushrooms on my podcast there we go
right there yeah yeah you look high no i
was high
i'm gonna give this puppy 20 minutes and
we're gonna come back and i'm gonna be
on
shroom
i just want to tell you when i close my
eyes it's going like this
this is this is christian's vibration
brother
and then he's sitting on my lap more
feminine for some reason i don't lie
you know
this is like legitimate like i feel like
i'm upset i feel like i'm hanging upside
down like i'm aware that we're honestly
man you know who then you know who our
mlk is mgk machine gun
i don't remember i was blacked out
yeah people were mad at me about that
let's see look at that
[Music]
how are your family look at that what's
the [ __ ] i just sit on your lap there's
my daughter bouncing around
you know it's mike you saw my
six-month-old daughter jumping around
and that we call it a jump rouge started
jumping in after the
show that's cute
that's cute that's good so yeah so your
brother's got a hell of a bot and the
thing is the thing is how do you feel
about about your brother uh and his
acting career what do you think where do
you think it's going to go you love it
yeah i love it i think he's going to be
a superstar right so is there any
jealousy at all you're happy doing what
you're doing you're happy for him yeah
i'm completely happy for him i have no
jealousy for that at all he's been a lot
of help for me yeah you know what it is
older brother i'm the youngest you're
the youngest and you have a lower half
like a catcher you haven't asked like a
catcher
you look like a mlb catcher slash school
cafeteria lunch lady ass yeah right i do
but that's a positive yeah i got cake it
supposedly has a piece on it
your brother told me i have a big deal
your brother told me you have a big big
dick do
confidence you guys ever do a little
meth i'm being honest um
a little blow no because it's it's
prevalent in your in your community no
we uh
not providence warwick yes it's huge
meth area um no i didn't do any drugs
until or drink really until i grew up
talking are you hot what's going on
he's shaking his foot the whole show
you're on some sort of supplements yeah
i took an adderall like at seven in the
morning but you're you're prescribed
yeah yes how many milligrams were
talking 20
this morning yeah what's the dog tag for
saint christopher i was saying
christopher was the painter saying to
traffic right
um i think he is i think you're wearing
the patriots stain of traffic maybe i
i'm pretty sure it's just travels no i
think oh maybe it's travels yeah yeah
traffic that traffic
chrissy feel me on i don't know uh the
i'll fill you up thank you oh my god the
show you do with somebody did did they
break up did the the crew break so so
well i the the joe gotto what's it
called what's the show called and
practical jokers yeah i guess they broke
up no they didn't break up no they're
still doing the show no they broke up
i'm announcing it now they broke they
hate each other spread these rumors no
no no joe's a great guy joe gotto great
joe god is great guy they
he you know announced publicly he's
going through a divorce with his wife
and you know just couldn't mentally or i
guess didn't just want to do the show
and um and uh so they're going with with
just the three of them and i don't know
what's going to happen uh like what the
episodes are gonna be like but i know
it's just the three of them so and
truthfully because you know me i'm in a
[ __ ] wild mood today i've had too
much coffee i would spill some beans and
just you know i don't know anything i
truthfully don't know and i wouldn't
even ask sal nor do i i
who um with a with a uh uh
uh media conglomerate um uh because um i
i didn't want to do a second season of a
television show
so then you got a little thing called
the lawsuit yeah coming at ya and you
just get hit with an email and then
you're like that's a big number can't
afford it and and then
and then you say hey
whoa light bulb just went off i changed
my mind can i do a season two and they
say too late [ __ ] oh you're getting
dude
this is where your agent should be
taking where your agents are just dude
i've been yeah i could have yeah let's
jump back isn't it nuts i mean who are
your agents just actually fired him no i
don't i
would you mind calling people that have
been around for about 30 years like i
would have told you you can't they they
lock those cars but there's a way to do
but but there's also a way to do it and
get out correct not get in suit you get
you you suffer from exhaustion anxiety
there's so many ways yeah well the
problem is i yelled on my podcast it's
not enough money for me [ __ ]
like i was yelling things like that and
they they're citing some of the things
i've said on the podcast
yes such as you're on this [ __ ]
[ __ ] show and make more money on my
couch [ __ ] and then yelling at the
producers so that was a little wild what
was the show ah well the thing is i was
told by the lawyer not to mention it and
uh it's not so let's not be off the air
i'll tell you it's just a show about
construction and
and he was he would fill in and do king
of thing while he's filming out here
yeah yeah you have to rush back yeah so
who's who's the network no i can't tell
you that can't say anything but i'm
trying to get you in trouble
the truth is is i i you know it really
was like my my girl you know i have a
sick six-month-old daughter yeah so you
know i thought if things could be in new
york i would do them in new york no
problem but to to leave for months on
end with a six-month-old daughter with
we bought a house my girl doesn't drive
like i was like this is actually i
cannot do this like and so so it's
genuine like a truthfully like a real
family where was the show issue here it
was originally in l.a but my family was
here my girl was got an airbnb jasmine
was pregnant he was out here that's what
he's like once she had the baby though
we thought we thought they were gonna do
it in new york and i could be home and
then but i can't leave for three four
months with a six i just can't do it so
that's really truthfully the reason but
you know i was told not to talk about it
and not even mention it up even the
slightest but i say what's what are you
am i going to sell less tickets i can't
they yeah yeah yeah you can't get it
you're not going to get any worse than
seven percent of the room
chaos right yeah okay turn anything into
ticket sales anything dude that's what i
do with that daytime [ __ ] like you know
i'm like because because i remember i
did the wendy williams one and one of
the people i was on the show with
because whitney cummings was hosting
wendy williams and i mean i was like
laying bombs out there like [ __ ]
bombs and and and the crowd was like
what i mean you know the makeup people
like just get out of here because i mean
they were jokes like i was doing [ __ ]
bits yeah you know and your crowd was
doing jokes and they were like you know
you have to take things seriously and
everybody gets like applause breaks over
there for saying [ __ ] fluff i was
like i'm i'm trying to do [ __ ] jokes
here like about what a nightmare you
know it must be for travis barker dating
whatever kardashian he's like just then
they're talking about how nice and fun
it is i'm like ugh get out of here you
know so so i was just trying to do
comedy and then one of the panelists on
the show because it was bad she she
called me after and she was like you
know i've been there before like this
sob story about bombing i was like lady
i'm going to take these clips and
they're going to get hundreds of
thousands of views and i'm going to sell
out the beacon
because then you know her tickets were
you know she can't sell a 300 seater and
i'm like you what you you're lost with
entertainment like if you're going to
take that [ __ ] seriously that's fine
nobody's buying tickets to a comedy show
you have to do comedy all the time even
if it's uncomfortable yeah yeah so so
i'm like that's what i'm i'm never gonna
[ __ ] sell out and be like oh let me
just because i'm on this show and
they're setting let me just hear what
they when he was like no i'm gonna do
the [ __ ] jokes i'm gonna yell i have
warts and it's like if it bombs like
have you ever seen one bobby lee or
sigur or mark norman did like the the
show
and at the time like i'm sure everybody
watching the the especially the news
anchors were like what the [ __ ] yeah it
has because i don't know how many
millions of views observant of you let's
laugh
yeah dude you want to talk about ticket
sales tom segura i don't know it's weird
to me people don't you know his
residency in in las vegas oh i was there
playing and uh he's like dude you're in
vegas i'm like yeah where are you at
he's like
mandalay i'm like oh i'm a wise guy i
said yeah i'm here every month i have a
residency i'm like okay
people don't realize but what tom did
besides besides rogan what he did is
what the thing i think we all are doing
and continue to do is put your hand put
your career in the hands of your fans
and then you're safe yeah that's what
tom did yeah hands of the fans don't
give a [ __ ] about all this other
[ __ ] and listen if it comes it comes
but it's like i care about my fans and
my fans only that's that's what i'm
doing this for i don't care about all
this other [ __ ] you know you don't
need everything i make everything a part
of the show i've tried to be like
everything on the christy chaos podcast
is a part of the show whatever happens
we bring it in and we talk about it
because i don't know it's real life i
don't want anything to be like staged or
manicured or i don't feel like we don't
live in a now like everything's been
exposed yeah i'm like let's just be real
then everything not only has ever been
been exposed but it's being more and
more exposed that pretty soon
there are no secrets anymore even
celebrity like the whole idea when i was
coming up celebrity was like you saw de
niro in in a real situation
five minutes
right for five minutes once a year i had
no idea how he dressed right he had no
idea about his political beliefs nothing
how i feel about vaccinations right now
mystery now we're like oh you're a
[ __ ] regular dude who happens to make
believe for a living
that's what this whole podcast and now
it's like i'm not going for
generally
famous or j i appeal to everyone no you
got to go
you won't be as big as your niche you
know try to get your niche as big as
possible but it's like i almost love
that i can in certain markets sell
tickets but also ren remain pretty much
anonymous because it's like some of my
peers you know some of you know some of
my peers who are really like old school
television famous
they hate their they can't walk down the
street they can't do anything
i can still sell tickets and give my
family the life that i want to give them
but also remain you know pretty much
keep like my anonymity yeah
which is a beautiful thing around they
don't give a [ __ ] i'm not poor enough
but i'm still going i'm still going
ready for this i'm still going if it's
two thousand miles or less i'm going
first three thousand miles
economy uh uh uh um uh extra legroom so
yeah you know what i mean you know what
i was just saying i'm in that leg room
europe i'm going economy middle
europe what can you do you're up i gotta
go business
no no i'm saying where i'm at
financially no i don't know what i mean
i understand yeah no listen you know i
got a bmw 2012 but
well first class ticket by the way to
europe will cost you 10 grand a lot of
times yeah if you want to spend 10 grand
for five hours six hours or or maybe 11
hours yeah all right i mean sometimes or
you can spend a grand for like you know
yeah comfortable
comfortable what economy premium economy
premium it's hard to spend an extra nine
grand for that i feel like i'm getting
perhaps
we do economy pre ready for this here's
another chris and eddie idea going to
london economy middle seat we're going
to do a glass of wine and an ambien
that's the show patreon.com christy
comedy [ __ ] light it up
you're gonna be a drug addict by the end
of the well yeah my family has actually
had an intervention with me and said you
know we know you're doing the chris and
eddie show and you're having fun once a
week you take some type of substance an
edible a mushroom you know and you drink
a 40 which is fun it's great but you
know you're not like this you've never
really done substance or drank anything
before so we were a little concerned
about him you know more eyes than what
and i said i said listen mom
you're not my mother anymore the patreon
is i said that's who i [ __ ] that's my
lord and savior i said my lord and
savior is patreon.com so back off back
up [ __ ]
she said uh she said yeah no you're
having um
you know you need to you need to slow
down i think i think you're uh i think
you're pushing things down i said well
you know what mom you're right and uh i
said you know mom you're right i said
mom you're right nobody knows me better
than you i mean i came out of your body
and uh yeah it's actually what i like to
call a cry for help so that's what i'm
doing so you've only done you've only
done edibles
mushrooms and then 40s and then 40s and
then we smoked a little weed
we smoked a little weed once and then um
um we are going to do uh acid meth no
not method nothing like that you know
how big of a show you'd have you've
tried methamphetamine i'm going to do
that i'm going to trick up
you
but not the [ __ ] for locals no i mean
have your boys get the original four
loko that killed i don't think they have
that you can find it
about a 40 ounce no no
people die from it you can still get the
original one though that's what we'll do
extreme
search the dark do that on the five
dollar tier
there you go original four little you're
not a drinker really yeah it was a
caffeine content no honestly sometimes
sometimes on the patreon we don't do
chris and any show but once in a while
what i'm gonna sometimes i just to be
honest with you i like i've taken an
inedible once in a while i've gone to an
age where it's like sometimes you just
need to calm down you know
because that's why i understand 500
milligrams of caffeine in the originals
right people in harsh coffees is that uh
so how many milligrams in a coffee is it
says 156 for 156 milligrams in a tall
small coffee 160 for starbucks yeah so
what are we doing so 500 we're doing
about what three coffees
hey how much caffeine's in uh eight
shots of espresso that's what i drink
every morning every morning i drink so
you could probably handle that five five
hundred dollars that would do nothing
yeah dump her on there now i take eight
shots it's not hell of an ass i think
it's uh you do
so eight like a 64
dude you know what have a little four
loko 512
512 512 are you a coffee guy there's a
lot of student loans out there man
people are sick of it you gotta get rid
of your student loans or at least learn
how to refinance this you can save
thousands with refinancing if you know
where to look yeah and i'll tell you
where to look i'm gonna stop you right
go to earnest.com ernest was voted best
student loan refinancing overall by nerd
wallet okay earnest has some of the
lowest rates flexible payments an
in-house team ready to help you
with earnest you could change your
interest rate get a lower monthly
payment you never pay fees not even late
fees by refinancing can reduce your loan
term save money or combine multiple
loans in a simple monthly payment if you
have questions you can talk to a real
human real human machine an actual human
being brian with earnest it only takes
two minutes to see what your new rate
could look like all right it doesn't
impact your credit right now ernest is
offering the firing kid listeners and
viewers 100 cash bonus refinance your
student debt at earnest.com fighter not
available in all states once again you
can get a hundred bucks when you visit
earnest.com fighter to refinance your
student loan hit them with that thing i
don't want to visit
earnest.com details not available in all
states terms and conditions apply
earnest student loan rent and financing
made by earnest operations llc nmls
number 120 4917 california refunds
number
605-4788-535 mission street san
francisco california 94105 visit
earnest.com licenses for full list of
licenses
512 512 are you a coffee guy
big coffee guy me too i go this is my
third iced coffee of the day i don't do
tea i should do tea yeah but i don't do
tea but i like i like a little coffee
you don't much care about what kind of
coffee as long as it's coffee because
i'm a coffee i go iced coffee black and
i was taught to cincinnati i i was in
cincinnati for new year's eve taft
theater missed a sellout by about that
was truthfully 200. okay someone by 200
but i was with sam volcano so sure um so
so um i was there new year's eve and i
went into a store and i said hey can i
get a can i get a black iced coffee and
the you know the person behind the
counter was like excuse me the barista
the barista and i said can i get a black
iced coffee what and they were like
don't you want to change that tone a
little bit i swear to god and i said no
seattle cincinnati and i was with
jasmine who's puerto rican and i said um
i said i looked at her i was like what
am i doing and she said to him she goes
do you want him to are you like i have a
problem because he's saying black iced
coffee she was like and the guy was like
yeah i just think it's like in 2021 like
no no
it's a coffee with no milk and i was
like and then it was a white guy and i
was like
what
i was like i would have punched him in
the no no yeah that's what you want to i
mean i wouldn't have but that's where
you want to just we're we're in seattle
remember i went to that hipster type
store and go
you know especially like the capital you
know with the capital street what's it
called like in seattle it's like you
know the main area where like the gay
area is at
so there's like not a google there's
like trans people walking out whatever i
go in a coffee shop
and the
the barista or whatever made coffee look
like me but had long hair black
fingernails i didn't think anything of
it makes me drink nothing wrong i go hey
bro we hand me a straw
and he turns around and goes bro
now what he goes bro you mean miss i go
dude if you don't give me a [ __ ]
straw i swear to god and he gave me a
stroke you get did you say
i was like dude i swear i'm not playing
this [ __ ] dude give me the [ __ ] straw
man he gave me the straw i walked down
like dude you believe that [ __ ] like it
was it was right but but also like on
the name tag it said like bill
it said like dave or like a very manly
and there's no pros like narcissism if
on the name tag
if he had a dress on the name tag said
whatever pronouns are her whatever she
then i've been like hey uh whatever you
could could she hand me a straw i went
disrespectful i'm just narcissistic i
was like hey bro can you hear me
look like bigger beard than like bear
down yeah so so if we're gonna really go
with the truth is whatever you say it is
then there's no truth we can't get
offended if there's something especially
if you didn't know it's logically it's
like impossible i'll obey the the
pronouns on their name tag you know what
i'm saying but it's
it's logically impossible to [ __ ] um
but how would you know society
this coffee guy over here in this this
milky milk cross and i said uh i love i
love how his hair is uh you know i love
the way his hair is he had this long
hair and he said
her and i went okay you see now that
means i'm old and she she looked at me
and she goes it was a guy who
transitioned and he said you're totally
fine you're doing you're doing great
yeah it's just a new thing and it was
like i appreciated that she appreciated
who realizes that this is 15 seconds old
it's 15 minutes old this whole
transgender thing yeah it's 15 minutes
old and i don't have any issues did that
turn on a little bit huh did it turn on
a little bit can i be honest
can i be honest yeah
a little bit like yeah i mean look
here's the thing here's the thing
here's the thing yeah i'm a straight
chrissy i'm a straight guy i know a
straight man right yes until midnight
until midnight oh no now listen
i have deep feelings of kinship for
friends yeah you know he and i love my i
love my boy right here no matter what he
knows this i send a video me get i'm
having this procedure done on my leg to
fix my hamstrings
he sends me a video back it shows the
football game like yeah great game he
was great and he's just rubbing his dick
through his sweats he needs to see what
i'm working with yeah right and i've
seen him you know he also knows what
time although yeah but she needs to know
but you forget sometimes what time it is
so i remind my friends now now here's
the thing here's a lot
sunday afternoon it is a lot and it is a
lot and it's probably pushing a little
you're with your family you don't need
that
now here's the thing though i do there
are times and here here's what i have to
say about all of this i told you that i
spent time with tom cruise okay i had
one-on-one conversation with him for an
hour and a half at a party and we were
really talking and not only that i had
done a reading with him no i'm telling
you i had done a reading with him where
like six people in the room and we had
all our scenes together for a script
called the men that never went so i felt
we talked about wrestling dan gables
wrestling kim i felt like i had a
friendship and and the best part was he
goes you were great in that reading tell
me thank you i've told the story thank
you you were no you were great that
thank you your timing was
you were great in that coming from you
man means a lot he said that 13 times
now wait
so i'm talking to him and we're talking
about we had our kids the same age and i
i went i remember thinking to myself
and orlando bloom was there too and he
said hi he was very nice to me and i
said i would if nobody's looking and tom
cruise wanted to make out with me
i don't know how i would say no i'd be
very
what would i say you would do it i was
so starstruck that i would do that but
now that's good no that's peer pressure
that's peer pressure because i don't
want to be light it's your own problem i
want to be liked
it looks pretty there's no pressure
nobody's looking though
nobody's looking at how's my career
right now when i see a lady just sign up
for a science a man who's a lady like
like you know you and i know that that
one coffee gal who used to be a guy
remember in the old studio breathtaking
right gorgeous girl thank you no man
though
a brazilian man in a dress now
breathtaking right now if you don't
think there's something about him you
get some about him look i'm not
attracted but my can be broken i can if
there's nothing else around there's
nothing else around and i'm drinking
maybe i'm a little tooted up you never
know
i can be broken yeah you brought her on
chrissy chaos and i did shrooms with you
yeah i did kiss her you know what i mean
listen like
i
and that but that's to me that might be
because she's very feminine though right
so i think i've said this many times on
on podcast before but the way i describe
myself and it seems like you're in this
category is i fall in love with men i
have sex with women that's where i'm at
so emotionally i'm more connected to men
yeah and i still have sex with a woman
yeah i mean you know you're bi yes no
because i've never knowingly had sex
with a man
um my joke is what happens when you're
unconscious you're unconscious yeah this
is wild here's my here's my joke here's
my joke it's not even a joke i've seen
men
you and i were on it when we saw that
that black dude who was a running back i
think for the giants where his he had a
shirt off and i went there's one i go if
one more person asks me if i'm a pro
athlete i'm going to bust yeah i started
saying barkley was it take one no it
wasn't questions that's a good example a
little horny off those thighs i don't
know what the hams
he's the best running back then i found
when he's healthy and then he wears that
little loop earrings he's a giant [ __ ]
now but dude when he's healthy yeah
but a guy like that you you all of us
have seen a man
with a shirt off or just in a pair of
shorts
who's so breathtaking that you don't
want to have sex with them but if you
had to rub them down in oil yes
you would it'd be it'd be kind of a
field day for your hands like you'd be
like this is these are goals you'd be
excited about it yeah it'd be like
whoa
look at this because it's you're you're
you're looking forward to it well all
his you'd say to yourself look at all
these bits and pieces yeah but are you i
saw a guy in manhattan beach yesterday
was wearing those tie shots he had nice
big thighs and he said i want to sniff
his butt a little bit well that's
pushing fine yeah
but
my question for you while you rub them
down are you do you have an erection
because then you'll be a gay man no no
no i don't have an erection you have an
appreciation for it i go like it's like
nice cars this is the best i say all i
do is i go like because you don't know
cars
you treat a man like a car i go like
this i go i go yes i go i go you're back
i go you got a lot of you got this the
best i go you got a lot of
nooks and crannies
yeah that's not gay that's just an
appreciation yeah you got a lot of
nooks and crannies
i'm comfortable with who i am because uh
there's a character on my podcast
christy case podcast tt jerry who's
transgendered uh uh my jasmine my
girlfriend's um uh godfather
too different from the mother of my
children now if the lights were up we've
had a few cups of you know what i mean
your girls was so much higher without
your help
how dare you well how dare you
i will say they're both beautiful and
and and just the thing is it's like it's
like oh i didn't realize jessie reyes
commented
[Laughter]
hello who's that um yeah well she's a
big one
yes
oh hey if she has a [ __ ] i'm in um so
so i yep yep we can get off this because
probably all right here we go um so
so um yep wow that yeah
you can't do anything you don't [ __ ]
around that that's that's when you have
a latin lady saddle she can't do
anything she'll set my cars on but with
tt with
um by the way tt hilarious tt was
talking about life and death the other
night with us with me my kids went to
sleep with me jazz and tt and she was
just saying like the thing is with a
person like tt jerry what's so beautiful
about her as a human being is she was
incarcerated for 24 years i think
she went to jail you know it was a grand
larceny theft this that but then she
kept what happened was it's in prison
she kept getting what she had the five
o'clock shadow there
sometimes she you know somebody says
she's [ __ ] she straddles both worlds
sometimes you know like the other day
she went to go pick up my stepson she
was wearing one of my sweatshirts and
jasmine's high-heeled shoes and they
wouldn't give her my stepson rightfully
so so we have to call this quantity
she's fine
that's your sister's uncle this
is girlfriend's uncle that's her
godfather yeah that's her godfather so
right there and now godmother but she's
a beautiful person and she said i spent
so much time you know incarcerated for
different crimes because she kept
getting put getting added more prison
time when uh she would do things in
prison to get like for example a guy
kept coming to her cell and putting his
penis his flanced penis over into her
cell and she was like i don't like this
like this is stop doing this and then
one day he put his penis over the cell
and she cut it off or cut a tip of it
off with a tuna can oh so yeah okay so
that so you can it's going to hurt so
tuna can so you get solitary it's going
to hurt you get solitary for that yeah
and another instance where a security
guard uh he said was you know really
like assaulting her and being uh you
know really not nice to her and all this
stuff so what she did was she took a
couple of days worth of [ __ ] and pissed
she put it in a folger scan and she
shook it up and she threw it in his face
yeah another two in solitary for that
that's a tough yeah so so she so so
jesus christ so you keep getting i think
i'd rather have my dick cut than have
prison fights [ __ ] and all that [ __ ] two
days old she just kept letting faster
the folgers can't so so does she have a
man in prison so here's the interesting
part one of her on and off again
boyfriend's after us on the podcast with
the son of sam they were in the same
prison together she was just pretending
david burke she hung out with him it was
her on and off prison boyfriend and then
we had a guy
shut up no well because at first it's
hard for us to you know verify things
but then she told us the prison she was
in he was in that prison and then we had
somebody because certain inmates get
privileges of social media so there was
a guy a murderer in there i cheat or
something like that i forgot sure
message the homeless pimp he messaged he
listened to the podcast and he messaged
the homeless pimp's uh instagram saying
that is i can verify that
they were on and off again and son of
sam was upset he got transferred
then also amityville house murder uh
ronald defeo he said that she said that
he they would sell like shared a wall
and what she would do is put on like
little skimpy outfits you know like cut
her pants up and make like little thongs
and he she would uh let him uh hold
amira out and she would shake her esthel
up and he would jerk off to that that
was you know she's like i wanna and she
likes bad boys she told me yeah i said
who was crazy or son is sam or
defeo she goes to fail by a landslide i
said really she said to me this was two
years ago to do all the murders but yeah
no but she said that before the netflix
documentary came out i think yeah she
goes he didn't do all those murders and
we were like whoa but then she said
defeo she said defeo was a true nut he's
amityville horror house if they made a
movie about it he killed his entire
family and said the house told him to do
it
every day she said he passed away
recently but every day you would talk to
him she would bring his coffee she would
like go get his meals from she was like
his like little like prison girlfriend
like prison wife she said um every day i
talked to him and you know to be the
same thing hey ronald how you doing he'd
be like hey how you doing jerry i just
wish i killed my grandma
like that like he he every day he would
say just wish i killed my grandma like
like complete obsession
yeah dude no she played basketball at
tupac right two months before he died he
was in he was in rikers island then he
got killed she was playing basketball
she was in bikers she said she said he
was mad cool everybody loved tupac of
course she was like i don't think that
everybody loved him even everybody was
happy she was in rikers for a while too
she was in rice for a little bit yeah
she was in rikers when lil wayne was in
there well i can't believe she sucked
off son of something sucked many times
yeah and she said everybody in prison
loves trump she was like they were going
the inmates were going for trump big
time he said all of them black white
asian didn't matter gay straight she
said because they said trump what they
felt was they said trump was real they
said he was real now whether that's true
or not they that's what they believed at
that time they're like he's [ __ ] real
they were like everybody else is fake
[ __ ] jerry was like as an inmate you
know we we feel like we're from the
streets and whatever and you we felt
like trump was saying how it was and
that's why people are getting mad too
bad they can't vote too bad they cannot
vote which i think is [ __ ] they
should be able to vote when you got out
of prison but it's she's fascinating
because she told me when she was talking
about she was like you know
i'd be so happy because the way my life
started was beautiful and if i die
tomorrow the way my life ended is ending
is beautiful she was like because of you
guys and the podcast and all you've done
and we were like getting like emotional
i was like oh my god that's so beautiful
and she's like don't don't cry for me
chris she goes i'ma still be sucking
dick in heaven
she's not ill but i think she just feels
like um yeah i don't know i think she
just is like hey if something ever
happened to me i just wanting to know
i'm happy i don't know why she she just
brought it up out of nowhere well but
it's hard right yeah she's 57 years old
you might talk about it i mean come on
20 years let's pull up that picture with
the thigh right there i mean what are we
doing here babe this one you know no
that you don't like a little something
like that yeah go down a little bit
click out of that one i mean come on
yeah what are we doing with the purple
dress is she on hormones she was on
hormones she was on hormones but then
when she got out of prison they stopped
with the hormones but that's why we say
it every week at patreon
patreon.com the portion of the patron
goes to continuing her estrogen therapy
so we've been pumping her we've been
getting her estrogen back and we used
some of the money from the from the from
the patreon so thanks this was in my
apartment
[Laughter]
children were sleeping in the next room
and uh you know just get a little dick
shake for the camera yeah and she's
tucked back there she still has the the
dick well yeah i mean right here looks
like a vagina but what she does she
tucks it back and then tapes it back and
it and it's a [ __ ] that's a that's a
person who truly feels like a woman no
you want to talk about and what i love
about her is she is because of the life
she's lived the minuscule [ __ ]
problems that we have not worried about
even when me and my girl were having
issues she's like you two are putting
yourself in prison voluntarily
she's like get the [ __ ] out of you're
putting yourself in a mental prison
she's like i was in actual prison
solitary confinement she's like get stop
putting yourself in prison if
if it's gonna work then make it work if
it's not to work then go on with your
life i like this one but she looks like
kris jenner that's a good that's a good
person that's a good person to have
around dude she's you know what is she
because she represents the truth she's
she wrote someone wrote kris jenner
i mean it's not an easy life no that's a
tough guess dude once she do cheats
solitaire two times in her life solitary
confinement for two years yeah only the
light of day
first meal 5 30 a.m if you're sleeping
you miss it second meal 11 a.m if you're
sleeping you miss it last meal of the
day 3 p.m you have to eat it then
if you cannot they come in an hour after
each meal and search for contraband you
can't hide bread or anything so tt said
she was like what i would have to do is
she's like i would have to put food up
my ass and then [ __ ] it out clean it off
and eat it she was like i had to live
this way she was like so this is what
she's like so i was really in solitary
confinement she said there were many
times where you know i would get angry
yell at a prison card they don't you
don't see anybody for two days you don't
need for two days but mentally she's
strong as yeah
that's what i'm saying when you talk to
her you realize like your problems are
[ __ ] [ __ ] like you know because
you complained to her about your theater
ticket sales yes
she was like she said the same thing
she's like she was like she was like you
know what's crazy too is because i was
like debating
john a light on my podcast john a like
that
so this one's a good question isn't it
john a lightning
john gotti's
because a lot of people like sam in the
book say i never heard of the guy
well but but i mean there's pictures
with a light and gotti and all that like
it's all very he he really did do time
in prison killed six people with a
baseball bat no joke killed six
different people his weapon of choice
was baseball pictures of him with god
and you had him on the podcast so he's
out of prison now john
so he did time in jail and and you know
convicted murderer and he ran it uh you
know he opened about it you know
cooperated to get less prison time
snitched this guy yeah so john alex he's
a dangerous dude so john eli he goes um
he goes uh that was god's son so john a
light um he came uh and did the podcast
in the house and you know jasmine was
like why you have convicted murderers in
the house
i said it's for the youtube
and so but anyway tt jerry and john were
on the episode together and they were
both swapping prison stories it's the
only time was it great on my podcast yes
the only time on my podcast why i had to
i had to listen delete no no i had to
delete stuff because normally we say we
don't edit we just go in and we roll did
you edit huh why'd you edit because they
started sharing stories together of who
they knew in prison and it came to light
that tt jerry had sucked a couple of
these italian gangsters dicks and you
don't want that heat no when eli told me
after the pawn he goes hey you know it's
your lie you're whatever you want to do
he goes i'm just telling you if any of
these guys even though we didn't say
their names get described and they can
figure out who you will get killed for
that because you're going to get killed
for that and i was like and i was like
holy [ __ ] but jared but then because
jerry was going off she was like yeah
and they were like oh i know that guy
and this and that but you know because
she was like she's first of all what
jerry told me she goes she goes
everybody comes into prison and says
they ain't gay and after six months you
gay that's what she said
everybody's gay she goes you got in
about six months and then you're gay i
give calendar two days yeah no i mean
she's got it
two days brian yeah well she told me she
told me in in in jail she was like look
because i asked her i said if i went to
prison what what what would be your
advice she goes i would say you were
trans immediately she goes i would start
asking for estrogen pills immediately
because then they're going to move you
to the transgender part of the jail
which is a lot safer they're probably
not going to hurt you and you just take
a little estrogen for a couple years she
was like maybe you'll like it you're
going to go get out of prison yeah but
i'm throwing them anyway i'm eating
muffins every morning yeah so what's the
difference yeah and so maybe it occurred
my appetite so that's what her genuine
honest
advice was and you know
the things about like listening to
someone like that just talk about prison
and what it's like
and her life is like the most minuscule
thing she's happy about like you know
when you say like you try to tell your
kids oh there's kids who don't even have
food but they're like i don't know what
you're talking about
she genuinely is like i am happy to be
breathing fresh air i'm happy that i
walked to the street corner and you know
hot dogs out of my [ __ ] yeah dude she
used to do that all the time she would
hide she would hide the hot dog what she
did she actually told a great story is
she would get the um they used her last
name was miranda they would call her jlo
in prison but they said that the
security guards everybody calls her jlo
in prison their security guards would
have to get every time they would give
breakfast sausages they caught on they
couldn't give the breakfast sausages
because they were sausage links to jerry
because what she would do was she was
upstate prison around the buffalo area
attica prison so she would go up there
she would she had a little shelf at the
top of her um cell and her window could
open a little bit she would open up the
window stick the sausage links up there
they would freeze now they're dildos so
she would she would you know you know
she would uh you know get the dildos up
her ass yeah and you know sausage upper
ass and she would you know you know uh
make everybody come with the dildos and
you know you can't do that even though
it's fun sure so even though it's what a
tough
what a [ __ ]
rough
buffalo in attica prison attica is where
they
like that is when you think about a
penitentiary like the worst penitentiary
oh why because the highlight of your day
is freezing sausages so you can
use them as buildings great weather
great great buffalo out of jail is the
worst the worst impressions
i like
great so she but she had you know she
comes on the show and she just
represents like this uh this other side
of like life where you're like wow like
you're so [ __ ] interesting and she's
funny without even trying to be funny
because her story is all like wait what
the life that she lived is [ __ ]
unbelievable like how old is this get
back to a light how old is she so get
back to eli so eli light is he was with
the gambino crime family right he was a
hit man yeah there's no doubt that he
seemed to have killed and enforced a lot
of the rules yes physically yeah so can
be no family yeah but he was but he was
never going to be a maid man because he
was human
he can't so he's a nice guy so we you
know became like you know is he a tall
guy oh sure
yeah but you know and and but [ __ ]
jack you want to talk about a handsome
man holy [ __ ] yes i mean when you sit by
him you're like wow we um you know shoot
stress
that's him right yeah
right now he'll [ __ ] beat i mean he's
a big guy i mean he he was a boxer 55 so
he'll hurt you he'll hurt you yeah you
know so but he told me when i was you
know i was talking just two weeks ago we
were talking and he goes um i was
telling him about my agent i was like i
kind of want to let go my agent i said
but you know it's hard to make that call
he was like send an email i was like i
can't send an email it's a [ __ ] movie
goes chris i killed people with baseball
bats i'd send an email
i was like
he was like he was like don't add any
any extra stress to your life just get
out of it and it was like yeah dude
you're addicted murderer just saying
he's like just send words he goes
everybody everybody thinks you're a
tough guy because you've got to call you
got to do a face to face he goes you
don't just send an email but why why is
there always why is there all this talk
about whether or not this guy was really
this or that i have actually never heard
that
he was funny because we were asking him
questions homeless pimp was asking good
questions like you ever like in the
middle of a kill or you know getting rid
of a body and like you have to take a
[ __ ] he was like yeah he goes one time
he goes with whatever they were
somewhere in pennsylvania they had
killed somebody and they were like you
know putting his body away in like the
early 90s he was like i had to take a
[ __ ] he's like and i just took a [ __ ] i
took a [ __ ] right on his body right the
hole that we threw him and i just took a
shirt around in his body because i
didn't mean disrespectful to the guy he
goes you know i can't have my dna out
there so we already dug all that [ __ ] in
this guy's body in the [ __ ] hole and
i was like and he was like you know he's
like i don't want my [ __ ] out there next
you know bear comes up beats his body
i'm getting caught and i was like and i
was like wow did that work out for you
goes not really he goes that's one of
the murders they taught me to from the
dna from my [ __ ]
when they found the body he goes i
didn't realize that [ __ ] dna lasts a
long time holy [ __ ] i was like yeah god
how long did he serve for those
murderers he served 10 years i believe
that's a long time yeah but but but it's
like you know it's all cooperation and
role but honestly man the podcast
episode was fascinating i you know he
was saying like some things that were
like i mean look he's got a podcast too
and he writes a book and it's funny man
yeah ten years yeah so um yeah again
being on wait he only did five though
yeah this guy i mean he's out he's
cooperating with him forever as well so
there's no doubt he was a gambino guy i
don't know what the [ __ ] i think it was
that he had a beef with uh sammy he told
me and he said too he was like he was
like and there's no like you know not
that there's no more mafia but he was
like he was like hey goes he goes you
know the way people get he goes he goes
yeah he goes uh he goes you know one of
the gaudy brothers sent me a [ __ ]
computer virus last week that's how they
get you back
he goes they sent me a [ __ ] they
hacked my instagram
does he know why the mafia was it just a
combination of like racketeering laws
and also just social media
what about with the unions and stuff
they still control the documents for
that but he said as far as he said once
once uh giuliani started for once it
became uh federal law that you know if
you're a mob boss you're the mob boss
and i commit the crime you're going to
go to prison it destroyed it yeah so he
said then and then once once the head of
the family is out then uh you know the
disorder no leadership because he said
he was like look he said he said i mean
disrespectfully he goes but you know a
lot of guys that you work with they're
not smart you know he goes they're
pretty dumb guys and he was like so if
you don't have a boss telling them what
to do he goes they just get themselves
in trouble right away yeah so he said so
it's very much like these guys will come
out on the street and commit a crime
immediately street guys like street so
it's caught up he said so it really
can't exist but he said it does exist
now in a digital way right like it was a
digital thing he was like you know like
that's where they're trying to get
that's like russia whether it's not
really
it's easier to get away well no no no he
told me i said is there anybody to watch
out in new york he said the russians he
said the russians still [ __ ] he said
they do things a little differently he
goes you don't you do not you do not
want to piss off a russian gangster it's
relentless he said they'll come at you
it's like years hundreds and thousands
of years of just like they just warfare
like he said you do not want to [ __ ]
with russia because i asked him i said
was there anybody ever afraid of and he
goes there's a couple of russian guys
that i was like you know holy i feel a
little uncomfortable around them oh wow
they said the thing is with guys like
that is you know they'll send your body
like it'll be they'll they'll do it
slowly pieces they have no emotion you
said you know they'll kill you like you
know they'll kill you with a coat hanger
like they'll cut your tonsils out
they'll do things like that weird [ __ ]
you know they'll rearrange your teeth
like he does do stupid [ __ ] god they get
very creative they'll skin your kneecaps
you know just things like what yeah you
know come on
like he said it doesn't even hurt that
much it's just annoying you know i got
to skip my kneecaps
guys like that i [ __ ] oh oh so he was
like you don't hurt him it's a pain
but it's been it's it's it's it's an
interesting but that's what i love about
doing the podcast it's like these
characters man where it's like you know
well eli reached out to me uh his
manager tell him you think he's a fraud
no i would never say that i i don't i'm
listen i just personally said wait bro
here you go that guy's not real though
right chris
online with sammy the bull in him
because i listened to a lot of sam the
bull and he
but then sammy the bull said i'm not
going to say anything but obviously a
light was the real deal obviously
but he reached out uh
his people reached out well there's
another guy over here that in california
one of like the top top guys um
michael he has a huge podcast michael
francis yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah francis
he was a real deal he's a real guy he's
he's out here in california how is he
yeah he's out here he strikes me as a
very intelligent guy like he's super
smart yeah he was you know you know we
think we're making money on a podcast no
this guy was making 30 million dollars a
week on a gasoline scandal yeah 30
million a week very very very good yeah
yeah he was a racketeer he he made a lot
of money he wasn't even a gangster
what's that show i went on with that
patrick beck guy yeah he had so he had
michael and sammy the bull
sit down and talk yeah they said michael
was just a beast dude yeah dude super
beast yeah he he's he's into he's into
jesus very smart guy though very very
very smart guy yeah i know he's he's 70
years old by the way yeah pretty damn
yeah
they're like they're like digital
superstars the other they're digital
that's the thing it's like when you can
make money and you're a businessman like
that it's like it doesn't matter he just
he just adapted to the next correct yeah
he's a multi-millionaire now office this
is like when will smith was like oh
instagram's the new media forum and then
blew everybody out of the water yeah
yeah is that that's what we're doing
though his dad is that was the original
gangster yeah richard never turned on
anything he's down i think his dad what
were they was it
that guy that guy was the guy who would
never turn he was the old-school
original gangster like oh he died in
2020 wow in new york i wonder if he died
in prison or if they let him i don't
know that he died did he go to prison
born in 1917 yeah that's he had to have
one to pray yeah he's sentenced to a
fifth grade he lived to 103.
holy [ __ ]
30 to 50 million oldest federal inmate
in the united states hold up and the
only centurion dude he was custody at
the time hold on check this out he's the
associate producer of a bunch of movies
this thing is he was uh texas changed
texas chainsaw massacre which earned
over 30 million
unbelievable that over 30 million he
invested 80 000 dollars
yeah
yeah his father said to him before we
commit a crime ten seconds after that
crime if you ask me anything about that
i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you i'm gonna
look at you and say i don't know what
you're talking about yeah yeah yeah yeah
there's a hundred and so
crazy what a great [ __ ] run
i gotta go do a dating podcast now
you do i don't know there's a lot of
miles or something like that
i don't know you do a dating segment
with uh what's going on
we did we we had um
we had a a couple of people reach out
and try to get a date with uh with tt
and we're gonna we're actually gonna
pick the winner at uh february fifth and
then pay for the date film it yeah we're
doing it
dude we had a couple get married from
king and steam we put together we got
married yeah yeah that's cool do you
watch uh sports you you're watching
these football games oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah santino was
with [ __ ] um homie from uh the kansas
city chiefs last night patrick travis
kelsey's house after the game oh wow
playing beer pong with patrick mahomes
damn [ __ ] guy yeah i like i'm a big i
love sport i'm a giants fan so where we
stand you guys are [ __ ] awful dang
are you a niners guy or a broncos guy uh
broncos rams oh real okay yeah rams yeah
rams i was um
i was posted on his ig chin yeah yeah
he wouldn't post it on his uh website
you know no you said podcast right no no
no
did you say podcast no no did i say
podcast i heard a podcast oh you said it
i said i'm doing it i gotta go
guys santino posted the yeah picture so
um yeah dude but uh yeah man
i don't [ __ ] know yeah look at andrew
baby right there kelsey yeah they became
good friends
um so
congrats to my boy right he's only for
two days
yeah that's what it is whitney cummings
just comments on everybody's [ __ ]
things people are thirsty out there man
i thought this was a fake picture to be
honest i thought that was not andrew
santino yeah that's why i did a laughing
thing i thought it was someone else that
looked like him i know right and
actually that look he looks like uh like
he's got stuff in his cheeks like he's
not like inside him yeah yeah yeah he's
got an acorn he looks older maybe the
pandemic that makes people lose the
light oh you did it yeah i thought it
was fake i thought it was like a
look-alike that's why funny
wow
all right baby well
i gotta give some good events i gotta go
i'm sorry baby oh gotta go now yeah look
five minutes five minutes i'm supposed
to be there at two o'clock
hollywood uh villal john nick villal the
villal files
because you're already going to be
really late and what you're going to
have to say is you got covered
you've got some aches and pains not a
big deal but yeah you'll be with them
yeah
files
no i got it because i had a manager and
that manager said you got to do this one
because you got to get a non-comedy
audience so oh i know
what it is you're a [ __ ] manager
you need a non-comedy audience
i'm sure it's great nick has a lot of
data experience
so he likes to think he knows what he's
talking about
so the bachelor's does this have we
never heard of this one should i not do
this one
that pop it's got to be a bit big check
if it's a big pot or not
i don't know how do we check that
you can't check youtube because like if
you look at like dak shepard's podcast
or mark martin they're not on video no
so if he is on video we'll see they said
it's on video so they said become camera
ready so that's 50 000 subscribers okay
and
not a not amazing million views
not amazing seven thousand views huh
keep scrolling down yeah what does the
show have 109 right
here i mean some are hitters and some
are not
i told him i told him that we'd [ __ ]
be there well you should tell him super
mario tell him tell him it's gonna be
late should i tell him i got eggs just
tell him you got some eggs no i would
say who's gonna listen to this podcast
personally
no you can we can edit this out but i'd
lie
you know that show's not big at all dude
i mean it's fifty thousand i'm sure he's
a good one but see that's the thing
though too like i'm not gonna name names
but that's the thing too like even like
i know it's maybe very inside comedy but
that's the thing too even with managers
and agents this is a peer driven thing
like they don't know what the [ __ ]
they're talking about if they don't like
[ __ ] about the game i'll give an hour
and a half to this and no disrespect to
that but it's like it doesn't help it's
not i'm gonna sell no tickets
no no no i have no manager i've gotten
rid of that i've i've been here i got no
i have an a g well technically right now
we got a gap in time baby yeah but i
have i'm making a decision tonight um
but if you don't go ca i'm gonna fight
you you're out of your mind if you don't
you're out of your mind he works with me
tim dillon
what are you doing we'll see all right
give us an event so you can get out of
here yeah and go do that
man well you know so this is a sad one
louis anderson had passed away from
cancer at the age of 68. comedy store
original
never met him great guy
did a couple shows was a great yeah i
did a show with him on super nice i did
a show with him one time
a benefit and uh and he i've never seen
this before actually my friend sam did
once but uh he
he wept on stage talking about his
mother wow about his mother protected
him and his brother and sister from his
tyrannical dad jesus christ his dad used
to get drunk and
and she said she she protected us and
he's he was hilarious
then it was this is was a benefit for uh
battered women jesus and then he spoke
about his mother and wept on stage and
then brought it back to [ __ ] comedy
and i just i remember going i was like
this [ __ ] can really do
something we talked for a long time
about that and i was like i've never
seen that
good that all right louis
we're going to fly through them for a
so gay man louie anderson straight man
yes very very gay gary gay man
i didn't know i didn't know that either
oh yeah yeah oh yeah he's out with brian
kelly
have you ever seen have you ever seen
alaska moments
no he played a woman he played he wasn't
transgender on his tv yeah yes he played
his mother he was a woman on it he
played and he does an incredible yeah he
won a bunch of awards
[ __ ] okay
yeah so mark cuban recently opened up
his own pharmacy online where he will
put up the price of generic drugs and
then show the markup that his business
is going to put on in order to sustain
the business and he's showing that a lot
of these pharmaceutical companies are
marking up their products to a hundred
to a thousand percent
i love capitalism you get a guy like
this who comes along and goes [ __ ] you
guys go up a little bit
so this could potentially change the way
like pharmaceutical companies sell their
drugs
like that of course because a lot of
times they repackage
well look at that it says uh no scroll
back up to the top of that
for example lukumia drug is priced at 47
a month on mark cuban's thing compared
to 9 000 bucks retail thank you that's
[ __ ] fun that's the beautiful thing
about a guy like a mark cuban like when
you have all that money like that you
can really just tell the insurance
companies no [ __ ] you i have more money
than you it says the market up on
generations average at least 100 percent
some cases a thousand and this is where
this guy is taking his money and making
the world a better place yeah i [ __ ]
love that [ __ ] i love mark cuban the
company doesn't [ __ ] love insurance
claims and requires customers to pay for
their they're motivated by pharma bro
they got that piece of [ __ ] oh wow
skrilly
that's cool good i like
so a man in the uk uh has this weird
thing where he'll go on grindr and
ha set up consensual sex dates with
different men he would then after go on
to his grinder profile change the bio to
say that he's an escort and how much he
charges by the hour in order to
blackmail these men if the men do not
pay him what he wants he'll put out the
information to like send it to their
girlfriends their wives or boyfriends
work people that they work with or he
threatens that he's going to well i know
how to meet up
he
was recently arrested because a few of
his victims had come forward saying this
is the man who has been blackmailing me
they arrested him while he was at home
with his girlfriend all right so he
wasn't gay so nobody would actually no
they would have sex okay so he's going
he would have sex with god
after the fact you can't be telling
people why is the logo for grinder a
batman helmet
i don't know i've never seen that it's
not all right yeah
is that is that really the logo it looks
like groot
yeah it does it's a good call
yeah
yeah do you ever go on it
i went i made an account as a goof once
yeah it's not listen you meet some nice
people well but did you just get a ton
of dick pics it's all it's all sex the
thing is nobody wants to have a
conversation guys it's just guys they
want to give us yeah using guys
entertain the conversation
and you're doing pretty well dude put
that put your butt on there i'll put
anything on there i'll put it i got more
my uh my butt has a couple no brandon
punching you and then you just come oh
no dude right away no just put frozen
sausages as your avatar dude i know well
i asked tt jerry if she wanted to grind
her account she said no why because she
said she said she she's like the guy
what she likes is to she likes to hook
up with men in alleys men that have like
she was like she's like she likes to be
a little bit street she likes the street
of it all yeah she's got a couple of
guys like she said she said you know she
she knows she knows because i asked her
i said am i gay because i feel like i'm
on the fence a little bit i feel like
with the right wind gusts i can be blown
over she said no you're not gay because
you're so comfortable with you know
sexuality she's like you're not gay
she's like but a lot of guys like to
wound up she said most of her boyfriends
in prison were had full families like
they were like you know had wives and
she said and even the guys on the street
that most of guys shook up with have
their have girlfriends and what yeah the
guys that are always like super anti-gay
and like he's gay yeah
the way we joke around like we're
clearly not
yeah yeah like what demons are you
fighting right like how i because i i
agree with you like you could put me in
jail i'm just not attracted to men i'm
just not i mean six months
i mean yeah
get a blown ass let's see what happens
just that
that would happen like on my some of my
cheer teams like some of the like the
straightest dudes don't like [ __ ]
on earth would [ __ ]
think around some of those dudes yeah
because they joined the team because
that they're gay and they they were like
maybe i'll join it's like all flirting
well like i mean they're all like no but
those those same dudes are married with
kids now i know but when they were
cheerleading but when they were like
when they were dicks
yeah yeah that's so interesting i had
this dude that i chewed with that was
hooking up with the football players at
our because it was a you know podunk
town that we were in you know in texas
or whatever cheerleaders would the right
i would see i was a football player yeah
and i would see
football players walking out of his dorm
room in the morning as i'm going to get
really
yes yeah
i see i i
i don't know i don't know if they're
around that culture all the time nah
you're rather attractive they're like
david you know
so a drunk irish man was on a flight
from dublin to new york and he's
currently facing 20 years in prison for
mooning a flight attendant he was
throwing like empty drink bottles at
other passengers very unruly the captain
actually had to take a break go back to
that guy's seat to talk to him like hey
can you calm down we're almost there and
he proceeds yeah he proceeds to threaten
to hit the pilot so he's now that's what
it is
because now be
you're on that flight yeah i'm [ __ ]
that guy up so i get to my destination
is that what you're doing a hundred
percent
i live for that moment yeah yeah cause i
feel like if you're on that flight
you're you're taking that you're gonna
you're gonna you're gonna put him in a
nice squeeze you're gonna grip and i
assume everyone's gonna applaud it yeah
yeah you're gonna give him a nice grip
down yeah yeah i'm going instagram live
[ __ ] paul and i don't want to hang
out with me me and chris dionne go hey
get your camera right you got a headline
you're coming up behind him and
seatbelting him what are you gonna do no
i'm just i'm getting his neck he's just
gonna go and just go you're gonna go
he's just gonna put that pressure on his
neck and make him like time just going
to choke him right out just right out
you just bring him i got to be honest
you've ever been in a fight
oh yeah a couple of fights yeah yeah uh
maybe three years
like a fighter i'm two for two some
would say one and three i say i'm two
that flight i mean it sounds fun i mean
honestly like i would be hysterical
laughing if some irish passengers start
just started mooning everyone hits yeah
me too i'd get hit by a bomb it'd be
like
until he bullies somebody or tries
that's too much that's my problem until
he hits races yeah that's right don't be
bullying otherwise i gotta fight you
yeah yeah then i'd get involved yeah uh
do you want to do more or uh yes yeah
look at that send me a text community um
yeah dude you know oh what shows yeah
there you go yeah we'll take a
screenshot okay there we go there we go
atlanta yeah atlantic 7 and
washington d.c
tabernacle atlanta we need you to get on
atlanta dc we need help with royal
royal's doing good hey how about this
good news for royal oak they just said
today at that theater and all of
michigan no vaccine mandate no cova test
you can come in like it's 2019 you just
walk in no masks whatever you want to do
so that's good news for royal oaks some
of the fans have been saying like you
[ __ ] vaccine mandate or you don't
have a vaccine mandate royal oak is like
it like the pandemic never happened so
come get tickets that's martin's theater
nashville tennessee ryman you're all
over uh well what's up [ __ ] logo
thanks dude uh wednesday is shauban
friends of the hollywood improv 20
tickets left it's also brian callum's
birthday wow we'll have some savages
there
uh yeah it's gonna be a good night it's
brian chelan's birthday the big boys
coming out for that 20 tickets left
hollywood improv one show one at only 8
pm and then atlanta georgia's february
3rd through the 5th sacramento just went
on sale february 24th through 26th
tickets at fatkz.com
uh you can watch the last cal bass fight
command ufc 270 chris delia brian callan
and myself right now we have food truck
diaries with sugar shawn is out right
now on thick boy and then we have a huge
guest doing a food truck tomorrow so
keep you guys posted las vegas nevada me
and sam tripley diversion amusements
we're doing two shows first he's going
to come up with a conspiracy theory i am
going to debate him i'm going to try to
debunk it and then we are doing stand-up
together diversion amusements las vegas
sam tripoli february 19. appleton
wisconsin skyline comedy club march 3rd
to the 5th louisville kentucky
louisville comedy club march 17 17-19
miami florida march 25th to the 27th my
favorite place in the world and then
february 25th and 26th i'll be in kansas
city missouri at the comedy club of
kansas city and then march 10th
through 12th i'll be at uh
the blue room comedy club in springfield
missouri
boom all right [ __ ] yeah chrissy we love
you brother love you babe donald trump
was it was writing a script the entire
show don don he's like a legend that's
what it is dude he's like a good man
chrissy d go see him folks we love you
thank you